what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we're covering part two of DC's
heroes in crisis and as I read through
this I started thinking about something
and I have a theory and I'll run over
that theory at the end of the video I
have an idea on who it is that's behind
it but anyway so as we know with heroes
in crisis so far wally west and an
arsenal are like the two big heroes to
die i mean we know that like like the
heroes in crisis event centers on the
creation of something called sanctuary
but sanctuary was a place where heroes
and even sometimes villains could go to
like get the burden off their shoulders
it was a place for those who have powers
where they could go and basically not
keep all their emotions and thoughts
bottled up and push them towards like a
breaking point because that's one thing
to bear in mind a lot of the heroes who
are out there are masked heroes they
have dual identities they they they
really can't just like walk into a
psychologists office and say hey Doc I
got problems I'm Batman
and I really struggle letting people
know that because I'm walking in this
balance line at being like Batman and
Bruce Wayne by the way please don't tell
anybody because all it would take is
just like a judge with a court order to
make that information come out I mean
they'd have to give it up and so because
of this they need a place where heroes
could go and talk they could to
essentially quote unquote confess their
sins take that burden off their
shoulders and go back to being heroes
again the whole basis behind this was
that someone somewhere went into
sanctuary and just killed a whole bunch
of heroes most of whom he hadn't even
heard of but a couple of big names were
in there you know again the death of
Wally the death of red arrow of Arsenal
that was pretty big stuff and so this
picking up with poison ivy is intriguing
here because poison ivy isn't so much a
tried-and-true villain anymore as she is
like kind of an antihero almost that
she's almost kind of reforming herself
you know kind of going back to being a
hero so does burly's becoming a hero so
to speak and it's kind of a cool thing
because you end up having Harley Quinn
who jumps in the middle of all this now
this is very easy to write off but it's
actually very very important because
what this tells us is Harley Quinn was
not supposed to be there that she was at
sanctuary we know that from the very
first issue she was at sanctuary but she
wasn't supposed to be there that because
of the fact that she is in love to her
and in poison ivy or a thing together
that she essentially just kind of snuck
along not only that we're not even
really told how people are supposed to
be there that poison ivy there but we're
not really told if you have to be
invited or anything along those lines
now we'll also get another another part
of this puzzle in Harley Quinn will kind
of reveal how it was at poison ivy got
there but what is it happening as Harley
Quinn is essentially like the way this
is written there are two things going on
one Booster Gold did it two
it looks like holy Quinn did an
introducer gold into believing that he
did it that's kind of how this seems to
unfold here and Harley Quinn showing up
at the lair of the penguin is basically
like hey look I need a place to lie low
for a while this is the other cool thing
to use what I love about clay man a lot
of times in in comic books for those you
guys who renew here a lot of times in
comic books you'll see different
villains draw in different ways and
sometimes you'll see them drawn in a way
where it's like that looks kind of
ridiculous right like you think of
Oswald Cobblepot and you think of like
the penguin from like batman the
animated series where he's more like to
do you know he's more kind of pom-pom
and circumstance and he looks very put
together and very like you know high-end
and very luxurious that's kind of how
his character comes across but then you
think about what the penguin would
actually be like in a city like gotham
city and it's like no he would be an
absolute disaster and that's how clay
man draws him and it's just kind of cool
to see you know it's kind of interesting
and Halle Quinn basically tells him look
like I have everybody coming after me
right now this is one of the most
important parts of the story it's partha
we switch to next that's why Tom King is
so cool
so Tom King so the way this plays out is
it's basically like like it's this kind
of discussion back and forth
Superman's like that man you know
Batman's like no I don't know and one
woman's like you're Batman of course you
know what's going on here like you know
how this guy died and Batman picked it
up right off the bat you know you have
this guy with with indestructible skin
and the whole stance is well somebody
put something in his mouth I mean if you
can't if he's basically like Luke Cage
you can't really pierce his skin then
somebody put something in his mouth that
made him swallow it and that's what
ended up killing him and it's kind of
crazy because Batman figuring this out
so fast you know leads to two men and
Wonder Woman asking questions of Batman
himself like you're the guy who prepares
for everything you're the guy who always
has an ace up his sleeve you're the guy
who's always got secrets like you use
this place like you can't tell us
otherwise you use this place to spy on
people like sure this was a place where
it where very people could go and they
could seek out refuge and they could
spill their darkest secrets so they
wouldnt have to carry those around but
you built a back door so you could watch
them so you could see what it was that
they do now this is really like Superman
- whoa no one's kind of throwing things
out there and really like speculating
more so than anything else but it makes
sense about man would do that that was
the whole basis of tower Babel tower
Babel established the Batman had these
protocols on how to take down each
member of the Justice League did he
never told anybody about the entire
Justice League felt betrayed by Batman
and it's like these offhand remarks well
know you've probably got like kryptonite
in your bat belt there's something like
that in Batman's like that's ridiculous
of course I don't it's these cool little
exchanges because what this does is it
throws into sharp relief the idea that
the Justice League doesn't fully trust
Batman but then we actually know finding
out
Batman himself went to sanctuary Batman
goes and sits down in the chair and see
this Tom King man it's nine panels long
and it tells you so much about Batman
right like he sits down in the chair
and he says I've trained partners to
work with me and they've become my
family and then some of them have died
and that's it that's all you get and he
just sits there and then he breaks down
and cries and he says I'm sorry and it's
just like holy SH it's one of the
coolest things about like people who
love Batman will tell you one of the
coolest things about Batman and maybe
you have to be a Batman fan to really be
able to grasp but it's like this is the
guy who never tells anybody anything
it's like this incredibly human side of
Batman that you never get to see but
from this point forward we pick up with
Booster Gold now Booster Gold is is one
of those guys who's as much goofy as
anything else like he's as much kind of
a hassle as anything else because
remember he's basically a fraud rile
he's a guy that never did anything with
his life he got tired travel powers or
time travel technology jet to the 20th
century and is like yeah in my time I'm
a hero
I'm Booster Gold and just kind of like
hoodwinked his way on to being part of
like Justice League International and
and so on and so forth but he's a guy
who's more apt to screw things he screw
things up then he has to do things right
and so actually I'm kind of take things
that are out of order a little bit
because what you end up doing is kind of
jumping back and forth between Holly
Quinn and Booster who actually gonna
kind of clear this up because the two
are separate and they don't really cross
over here but when is it happening is
Booster sits around and says okay so
like I'm probably the one who did this
Harley Quinn tells me I'm the one who
did this and I'm pretty sure I'm the one
who did this so I'm not really gonna
tell anybody that I'm the one who did
this but I'm gonna solve the crime so
that once people find out that I did it
well I'm also the guy who solved
everything so they'll just say hey you
know six in one hand a half dozen the
other and and we'll go ahead and let it
go that's how boosters that's that's
like a classic Booster Gold thing I
screwed up really bad here but I fix
what I screwed up so that means
everybody will forget that I screwed up
in the first place it's pretty classic
of his character and so when he goes
through and he starts thing he's like
okay well there were bodies strewn
everywhere so that of course the first
thing we have to do is figure out you
know who knows about these bodies you
know he's like if anybody in the world
knows about bodies it's Barry Allen so
I'll run to Barry Allen's here Barry
Allen what's going on I keep in mind
Barry Allen doesn't know about sanctuary
at least not to the extent that Booster
Gold does and for those are guys you saw
issue number one you guys know if you
guys read that you guys know what Barry
Allen doesn't know and so when you have
Booster Gold show up here and start
talking to Barry and say hey man look I
need you to tell me what's been going on
like like give me the information you
did about the autopsies with the bodies
of sanctuary Barry's like what the hell
are you talking about the whole time
he's fighting something he's like what
the hell are you
he's like you member what happened man
like you know what happened like
everybody is sanctuary died and like
berry doesn't know he had no clue that
Wally West died and the whole time
Skeets the robot of booster goes like
dude shut the hell up stop talking
because if you do you're gonna spill the
beans to Barry and he's gonna lose it
and the whole time that that booster
saying is he's like I mean I'm pretty
sure I'm the one who did it you know and
so just by connecting the simplest of
dots hey Wally West is dead it's
sanctuary and I'm pretty sure I'm the
one who killed him Barry races off like
he's he's I'm he's out in the time it
takes for who should have finish his
sentence Barry is there and backing him
and he even asks he's like how long do
you think it'll take him to analyze the
bodies and get back to like well
considering he's the fastest man alive
probably pretty quickly and and Barry
comes running in with with the wrath of
God and just punches the hell out of
Booster Gold while he's crying and is
screaming what did you do it's so cool
it's why I left Thom caked on keys
amazing at riding heroes and when he
rises like it's the super emotional
Barry out because he basically had the
the the beans spilled on him by a guy
who didn't fully grasp the reality
situation who's just kind of flying by
the seat of his pants being a super hero
and really doesn't seems to be very
cavalier about throwing that then
information out there to Barry which is
kind of surprising considering how much
Booster Gold knows about Barry and so
when that informations thrown out there
Barry is an emotional wreck and
absolutely loses it and who the hell
knows what'll happen after this and so
picking up with Harley Quinn Harley
Quinn and turn is playing go fish with a
penguin which it's Harley Quinn nobody
ever said she was sane so it's a Harley
Quinn playing go fish with a penguin
enough said which leads to the arrival
of like Superman Batman in one room the
Trinity basically busts into the scene
and say hey look we have questions we
need to talk and Harley just like like
it's almost like she prepared for this
because she basically says look like
it's crazy and there were bodies
everywhere and it's kind of like losing
your mind you know it's just oh my god
it was so insane and it was just this
overwhelming thing and makes your way up
to Wonder Woman which is a smart move
because Wonder Woman will be more likely
to forgive Harley Quinn and then Batman
or Superman
because remember Wonder Woman sees the
various female superheroes out there as
her sisters so she's not going to just
automatically lash out she's gonna
listen first but but this is the cool
thing
Harley Quinn makes your way up to Wonder
Woman and when she does she snatches the
lasso of truth steals it off of Wonder
Woman and in turn uses her acrobatics
jumps out of the way knocks Wonder Woman
out and then lashes it around Batman
take some hostage and this is cool
because
Harley Quinn knows Batman
like she knows how Batman functions will
she wraps it around him she literally
asked the question is there anything
that you have on you right now that can
be used against the Justice League and
Batman's responses you know like like
that like she was like no he doesn't you
know he told me he does and one woman's
like no this is you know no one wants to
believe the Batman's response there's
kryptonite my bat Bell it's in the
fourth powder in the third pouch on the
left and it's in a lead container damn
Batman's a liar lied to Superman right
to his face and Wonder Woman had to have
suspected it because she's not into now
she's not like oh my god really did you
just kinda like Batman yet again more
lies more trickery from The Dark Knight
and in turn like she grabs the
Kryptonite breaks it out you know uses
it as a way to distract Superman and
just races off and she's got Wonder
Woman in turn of course turns to
Superman chairs to Batman to tend to him
to make sure they're okay because she
would take the more logical stance to
say there'll be time to catch up to her
later which gives Harley Quinn D out
that she needs but this is yet another
instance where Batman is lying to the
Justice League lying to his friends this
same thing as always Batman lying Batman
being deceitful you know and Superman
kind of brushes it off in the moment but
it's also one of these things worse like
I guess it's kind of kind of expected to
be all but like the same as he makes her
you know it's like man she's good
you know she's as good as you are Batman
she's as good as you at tricking people
lying to people it's kind of crazy
because Wonder Woman is just like this
is not the time for this this is not the
time to get into a pissing contest and
to argue and bicker and so on and so
forth and then suddenly Superman picks
up on what's going on that Barry Allen
has Booster Gold the Barry Allen has
taken Booster Gold which means Barry
Allen now Xena now knows what's going on
and so this is when you basically pick
up with Harley Quinn which is on the top
of a bridge in Gotham and she she starts
talking about sanctuary and this is a
cool thing because what she says here is
she says I shouldn't have done all the
things that I've done like there's so
many things that I shouldn't have done
she says I shouldn't have let anyone
hurt you
I shouldn't have followed you to
sanctuaries like I should not have led
to let anyone kill you poison ivy I
shouldn't have told you about sanctuary
I shouldn't have loved you and I
shouldn't have met you you know I
shouldn't have done all the things that
led up to this moment
basically that poison ivy was told about
sanctuary and so it seems as though
sanctuary had an open doors policy they
they you didn't have to be invited they
that it wasn't only a limited number of
people it was for anyone which lives up
to the Charter of sanctuary as it had
been explained so far anybody can come
in here and anybody can confess their
sins that's what this place is for and
so it's kind of nuts because then you
switch over to the Daily Planet and
there's this package that came in for
Lois Lane like it's basically written by
arsenal saying here's the whole basis
behind sanctuary here's what this whole
place is about here's what we do here
here's how all this stuff works and if
any of us should die here
know that it was done by the peddlers
you know at least the package itself was
signed by the puddlers and so it's just
kind of like wow I mean like there's
these these hidden hands behind all this
and so this is when things get really
really really crazy because if every
because here's the thing you have to
remember all these confessions are being
made to computer systems and if these
confessions are being made to computers
then it stands to reason that all the
information would be deleted that's what
Batman says in the story no no no you
know this whole thing is there people
confess their sins in 24 hours it's
deleted so you can say anything you want
to what you have here gives you a
Superman who sits down and says I'm
Superman I'm Clark Kent
I was raised as the Kenton in Smallville
and then I learned my own history
I learned the fact that I come from that
I come from Krypton that in the presence
of a Yellow Sun that I have what amount
to basically godly powers and that I
lead a dual identity sometimes I don't
really know who I am sometimes I don't
know if I'm really Clark Kent or if I'm
really Superman and that's why I made
the identity so similar to each other by
just taking off these glasses and
putting them back on because if I made
them too extreme I would get lost in my
identities
I wouldn't know who I actually was but
it's something that he fears is
something that he's afraid of that he'll
lose his way but Superman just confessed
his identity to a recording device that
could very well have been infiltrated
and could very well have been taken over
now but do you know to what happens this
recording device I have no real idea I
mean it'll probably come out that their
identities reveal to the world and so on
and so forth but in terms of who it was
that killed everyone in reality if I'm
if I'm a betting man I would say this is
being done by psycho-pirate because from
from wine from what we gather we don't
know what happened to Psychopaths I mean
we know we don't really know the last
time we saw psycho-pirate was during Tom
Kings Batman run at the I am suicide
story and like psycho-pirate was serving
alongside Bane and then psycho-pirate
was taken by Batman in order to undo the
damage that was done to Gotham rule but
then like that's it like like as far as
we're aware him he wasn't killed he's
not dead he's just out there somewhere
and it's entirely possible that if
Batman sits down and Batman says let's
create sanctuary then Batman would have
to answer the question what do we do
with those who don't want to talk like
those who come here but then they they
they get hesitant and they walk away how
do we get them to talk and psycho-pirate
can do that he manipulates the emotions
of others but it would makes perfect
sense to me that psycho-pirate is the
man standing on the other side of these
recording devices the recording devices
are just recording devices but who knows
but like I feel like psycho prob you
would have a hand in all this that you'd
be the UV what amounts to the therapist
the person manipulating you know
emotionally manipulating people into
letting all their all their emotions out
either that or be like stop hiring
strange who were like Hugo Strange's is
in the shadows behind the scene
manipulating psycho-pirate
or controlling psycho power telling him
what to do psycho-pirate does that and
no one knows that Hugo Strange is behind
it all there's a lot of things that
could be going on here then the only
reason why I even think about Hugo
Strange I think about that old story
from from Batman the old Steve Englehart
run which they did in Batman the
Animated Series where he go strange was
was basically learning people's like
darkest secrets and then blackmailing
them and like paying him money or doing
in political favors you know again
there's any number of things that could
go on here but I'm I'm excited like
that's one of the coolest things I'm so
excited to see where this goes and I'm
so hyped to see what happens with this
oh that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here too comments explained make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]